anger in Senegal's capital supporters of
opposition leader Usman sonko have been
fighting with security forces schools
and shops are shut as violence and
looting spread from one neighborhood to
another they accuse president makisal of
using the justice system to eliminate
political opponents and cling on to
power
we elected makisal to work not to
establish a dictatorship he must leave
sonko alone if he does not we will burn
the country
in this heavily guarded vehicle is sonko
on his way to a trial that could end his
political aspirations he's charged with
slander after he accused a state
minister of corruption if convicted he
cannot contest the 2024 presidential
elections
as crowds gathered Security Forces
forced shonko out of his vehicle he says
he was injured in the scuffle the judge
hearing his case has adjourned the
proceedings because of sanko's injuries
but the fighting on the streets
continues moments ago demonstrators
stormed this supermarket in an upscale
neighborhood they try to take drinking
water rice vegetable oil
so much of these riots are driven by
people who feel left out by the
government
despite a booming economy inequality is
growing what's going on in Senegal it
goes beyond
Usman we have been on a roller coaster
in terms of polarization in terms of
exclusion in terms of
restricting and closing of Civic space
the court cases is rising political
tensions and deepening a sense of
injustice among those feeling alienated
by the state but wanting to get their
voices heard Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera
Dakar